get $3,000 that's what we do with our
public dollars we give it back to the
people the people that earned it
you
Oh
so proud a congresswoman Watson Coleman
and myself she's from New Jersey we
introduced legislation yes we introduced
legislation and saying no more non
driving factors it should be based on
whether or not we're safe drivers based
on the make or model of our car whatever
it is it should not be based on
non-discriminatory factors and let me
tell you here in Michigan no joke
somebody we're driving under the
influence violation with a decent credit
score okay credit score is paying less
than somebody with not a great credit
score but a hell a lot better driving
record is getting is literally paying
that person is paying 300% more than the
person drinking while drivin I mean see
that's that's what's happening so
justice for all Civil Rights Act is
important because if we don't get that
piece of legislation out we at least can
get them in the courts we must get back
to the original view of the Civil Rights
Act and ensure that all marginalized
communities have the protections they
need under the law to combat
discrimination both in the private in
the public sector we need bold action
folks and I know what's happening out
there you know there's all of this young
women and it's beyond just the four of
us the squad is all of you and I can
tell you there's you are all the squad
trust me if you for support echo to you
support justice you are one of us but
let me tell you this is the largest
incoming 10th class since Watergate
ironically and at the most diverse but I
don't mean just by color and make and
all these other things that they want to
label us as with some of us this is the
first time we've ever had health
insurance one of my colleagues until she
became a United States congresswoman Oh
another woman is a survivors domestic
violence some of us are hit hard with
college debt I have another woman who
literally congressman and Lucy Macbeth
lost her only son to gun violence and
she ran on that in one a district that
was a Republican district so no being
bold taking bold action
doesn't mean we lose it's the what we're
saying here is when we fight we win
that's how we fight we fight by taking
these kinds of actions and not saying oh
is this strategically the right thing no
is it the right thing is it gonna
provide justice for all and that's why I
want to leave you all with people said
Rashida this is not your time I said
well when is my time I didn't know there
was a line
[Music]
this is a new era of the civil rights
movement and until people like us in
this room run for office and get on the
inside and push back we're not gonna win
so not only in the streets not only with
legislation but also you run for office
that's how you fight and win thank you
so much
[Music]
let us give representative to leave
another round of applause
[Applause]
this land is indeed her land this land
is our land now it gives me great
privilege to bring to the podium and
welcome the 52nd Speaker of the House of
Representatives and congresswoman of the
12th congressional district out of San
Francisco California the Honorable Nancy
Pelosi
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning wonder to be here Thank You
Yvonne Thank You Yvonne white for your
wonderful introduction but mostly for
your strong leadership in Michigan let's
the air Yvonne wife let us all salute
Derrick Johnson for his leadership to
advance civil rights and equality across
America from sea to shining sea it's
always a pleasure to see chairman Leon
Russell a persistence and effective
force for change and it's an honor to be
here with each and every one of you
alright
and let me just say or they might hear
from California I know from San
Francisco Amos Brown is here and again I
I know Maryland is here in Baltimore is
represented here someplace
I represent San Francisco but I was born
in Baltimore and for my whole childhood
my father was the mayor of Baltimore and
then my brother mayor of Baltimore after
that so the names of Eno Liam McMillan
Peron and Clarence Mitchell and the
Murphy family were revered in our home
these er names I knew when I was growing
up and then 10 years ago
imagine the honor to get the
n-double-a-cp Center at the center and
double AC T centennial anniversary I was
honored to speak at the National
Convention in New York City and was and
became a golden heritage lifetime member
[Applause]
and now it is a great pleasure to be
with you here in New York in Detroit for
the end of a season one hundred and
tenth anniversary thank you to Governor
Whitmer for bringing us hope and to
married mcdougald for championing one
Detroit's for everyone for hosting us
this week we celebrate progress forged
over 11 decades of organizing and
mobilizing and we as we prepare for the
victories ahead because we know that
when we fight we win when we fight we
win I bring greetings to you from the US
House of Representatives the US Congress
the most diverse and dynamic Congress in
history and in our new house house the
house congressional by caucus the
largest ever historic 53 members in the
House of Representatives led by Karen
bass our fuller committee our fuller
caucus of the entire Democratic caucus
led by Hakeem Jeffries of New York and
of course we're very proud of the great
leadership of our House Democratic whip
Jim Clyburn so here we are with this
house Democratic caucus 60% people of
color women and LGBTQ community members
60% I mean the Congress our members just
don't serve they lead again I talked
about mr. Clyburn here in Detroit we
celebrate aniconic hero of the civil
rights fight and a beloved member of
this community and of our country Rosa
Parks I was proud to work with Senator
Harry Reid in the entire Michigan
delegation to ensure that Rosa Parks
would make history again as the first
woman to lie in state in the rotunda of
the Capitol
eight years later roses greatness would
be recognized again with a bronze statue
now joining Sojourner Truth and dr. King
in the capital of the United States Rosa
Parks made the decision to demand her
rights you know that and she later said
on that bus that the only child I was of
tired of giving in we too must be be
tired of giving in we too must continue
to stand firm for the fairness for
genuine genuine equality and for justice
the house democratic the Democratic
house stands with n-double-a-cp
in this mission as a proud partner in
progress we are here to listen to learn
from you and so that together we can
lead the way to a better future for all
the men and women I thank you I bring
thank you because so many men and women
of under a CP helped elect a Democratic
majority that would be there for the
people that is that on day one during
day one that what the for the people
agenda we passed the for the people act
to make government work in the public
interest the people's interest not the
special interest a key part of HR 1 is
protecting and restoring the sacred
right to vote which is under serious
sustained threat today our vote as we
know is our voice and must be protected
that is why a key pillar of HR 1 is John
Congressman John Lewis's voter
empowerment Act which ensures equal
access to the ballot mud of modernizes
voter registration and fights voter
suppression and that is why the house is
advancing HR for congresswoman Terry
civils voting rights advancement Act
which restores voting rights acts
ability to combat discrimination voter
discrimination
the Judiciary Committee and the house
administration subcommittees on
elections led by chairwoman Marcia fudge
who was here with us today will continue
to hold that earrings in the months
ahead we must create an ironclad
constitutional basis to restore the
Voting Rights Act and that's being done
under the leadership of Marcia fudge and
when we do the house will swiftly pass
the Voting Rights Act to protect the
ballot once we once we restore the vote
once we break the grass the gas the
grass of special interest once we put
power back in the hands of the people
the American people can finally and
fully achieve justice in America and
justice is something I want to spend a
couple minutes on right now 17th
centuries ago st. Agustin said any
government that has not formed to
promote justice is just a bunch of
Thieves
he said that what he said he said and
then others have said sometimes it's
hard to achieve justice but you to do so
you must avoid the dazzling blinding
blindness of special interest in money
who are there to exploit the people we
must achieve economic justice and the
disparity of income in America and
reverse the damage of the Republicans
special interest agenda that is why the
House passed Paycheck Fairness Act equal
pay for equal work for women in the
workplace and just last week we passed
the $15 minimum wage $15 minimum wage
the first time in a decade thirty
million people in America will receive a
raise 20 million of them women many of
them women of color a pay raise that is
so excited in the workplace we must
achieve justice in health care
understanding as dr. King said of all
the forms of inequality injustice in
health is the most shocking and the most
inhuman because it often results in
death I said dr. King said about that
House Democrats have now sent ten bills
to the Senate to lower the cost of
prescription drugs and health care
reverse the gops sabotage of the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare and
strengthen the pre-existing condition
benefit we must also achieve
environmental justice so that all
children no matter where they grow up
can breathe clean air and drink clean
water in May the house that Democratic
House passed the climate action knell
Act to take the first steps to
protecting our planet for our children
this year we advance robust funding in
the EPA to ensure clean drinking water
and we will continue to fight for
justice for families in Flint
we must achieve justice and education as
we observe the 50th anniversary of
putting a man on the moon just this past
weekend the vision of President Kennedy
remember his words our progress as a
nation can be no swifter than our
progress in education because at the end
of ACP education is the key to success
no matter what your race or where you
live and safe schools and communities
demand that we prevent gun violence once
and for all
that means we will not take no for an
answer on background checks that's why
the House passed HR 8 the bipartisan
background check act and with Jim
Clyburn spill to close the Charleston
loophole and congresswoman Macbeth has
been a leader in this fight for us we
must and we will keep working until our
children are safe in their schools in
their homes and in their neighborhoods
and we must achieve real justice in our
criminal justice system we cannot accept
a system in which the wealthy people
with high paid lawyers can plead
ignorance of the wall and not go to jail
while children born not in privilege
when they even assert their rights are
accused of resisting arrest we cannot
have that we cannot tell their system
that holds them to a different standard
of law the two-tiered system of justice
is discriminatory and every step from
policing to sentencing to imprisonment
and beyond it is unfair it is unjust and
it must it cannot stand at the birth of
our nation
in the dark days of the revolution
Thomas Paine said the times have found
us we do not place ourselves in the
category of our founders but we do know
the urgency of now that dr. King talked
about and the times have found us each
and every one of us in this room all of
us in Congress the two senators senator
Stabenow senator Peters my colleagues
congresswoman Lawrence congresswoman to
leave the times have found all of us to
make the difference that our country is
crying out for now again dr. King when
he talked about the fierce urgency of
now he said this is no time to engage in
the luxury of cooling offer to take the
tranquilizing drug of gradualism we all
know we must act boldly 110 years ago
the times found your leaders to forge
the n-double-a-cp and to fight for your
rights in the wake of the Springfield
riots I hear this all the time from
Shelley from our good friends in DC and
today the times have found us to us to
achieve a future to achieve a further
full of justice worthy of the sacrifice
of our founders that fight they made
thank God they made the Constitution
amendable worthy of there's a vision
worthy of the sacrifice of our men and
women in uniform and let us salute them
and
[Music]
have Liberty we make that pledge every
day liberty and justice for all
with your outside mobilising and our
inside maneuvering we can achieve more
fair free and just future making the
drill dream of Rosa Parks dr. Martin
Luther King and all who have fought for
progress many of them in this room let
us all week when we leave here remember
when we fight we win when we fight we
win when we fight we win god bless you
god bless america thank you all very
much for the honor to be here thank you
so much
[Music]